[Musique]
alors moi ce soir
j'aimerais partager avec vous des
histoires de vie très perso et de ses
histoires vous faire une proposition
liban en juillet 2006 cet été là c'est
la guerre des 33 jours entre le liban et
israël et en août je pars vivre un an
dans un échanges universitaires entre
mon école et sciences po beyrouth et
donc j'arrive à la fin de cette guerre
des 33 jours j'arrive à la fin du
conflit et donc j'observe d'un point de
vue extérieur un petit peu comme spencer
platt photo journaliste américain qui a
pris ce cliché le 15 août 2006 à la fin
de la guerre et j'ai envie de vous poser
cette question et vous que voyez vous
ici d'un point de vue extérieur du
voyeurisme peut être des touristes de
guerre en mal de sensations fortes
eh bien non la réalité est tout autre
ce sont des habitants du quartier des
victimes de cette guerre qui viennent
voir constater ce qui est devenu leur
habitat donc au liban comme ailleurs les
apparences sont trompeuses
moi ce que j'observe sur le terrain à ce
moment là c'est une solidarité qui
transcende les différences de confession
riches ou pauvres chrétiens ou musulmans
- ce que j'observe c'est deux mondes en
apparence opposés qui coopèrent alors là
il ya une idée à retenir deux mondes d
opposer qui coopèrent et j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure puis un an après je suis
toujours à beyrouth dans mon appartement
dans le quartier d'achrafieh
je suis dans ma chambre ma coloc dans la
sienne et puis c'est agréable la nuit
tombe on s'endort presque
hélas un bruit assourdissant retenti les
fenêtres du salon explose il ya de la
lumière blanche
la peur est là je vois au loin arrivé
comme un fantôme en fait c'est ma coloc
avec son drap de lit blanc sur sa tête
et là on est effrayé
est venu dans ma chambre parce qu'elle
pensait que la bombe avait lieu dans ma
chambre elle a peur il moi aussi alors
là on essaie de comprendre regarde par
la fenêtre on comprend pas on voit rien
on entend des sirènes
alors on prend les escaliers en descend
et là on se rend compte que c'est un
attentat à la voiture piégée juste en
bas de notre immeuble
donc là je n'observe pas cet événement
d'un point de vue extérieur mais je le
vis de l'intérieur est ce que j'observe
là c'est une étrange sérénité les gens
ne cherche pas à fuir les personnes sont
en bas de l'immeuble
elle reste là et ce que je vois c'est
qu'il ya comme en impératif à venir en
aide même s'il ya très peu de blessés
des personnes restent là et moi c'est de
cette réalité-là dont je voudrais parler
car à travers ces deux événements
concrets que j'ai vécues sur le terrain
ce que j'ai vu c'est de la bonté de
l'altruisme et du calme intérieur alors
là on est bien loin des clichés qu'en
temps de guerre c'est un pseudo un stand
sur vie égoïste qui surgit l'homme
serait l'homo economicus égoïste
rationnelle et tenterait de gérer au
mieux ses propres intérêts non moins
l'homme que j'ai côtoyés lors de ces
moments là de chaos
c'est le mot relational is l'être social
par excellence
parce que lors de ces moments là ceux
qui s'en posent à nous c'est un lien un
lien si fort qui nous lie en tant
qu'être humain en tant qu'espèce humaine
moi c'est de ça dont je voudrais parler
c'est de cette réalité là
puis dix ans après c'est un autre
événement alors je ne l'observent pas
d'un point de vue extérieur je ne le vis
pas de l'intérieur mais il me touche en
plein coeur c'est le soir je suis à aix
en provence en appartement enceinte de
huit mois et je viens de couches jetées
notre fils aîné alors je rentre dans ma
chambre pour prendre mon téléphone et
l'éteindre
hélas un sms arrive je vais bien
prévient les parents
j'ai juste une balle dans le genou mais
je vais bien ce soir là mon frère venait
de fuir une scène d'horreur les
attentats du bataclan c'est le 13
novembre 2015 appareil fait quand je
reçois ce que je ce que je ressens au
plus profond de moi c'est que je me dis
mais au fond pourquoi est ce qu'à ce
moment là je me sens aussi proche de lui
à ce moment là où je réalise que je peux
le perdre qu'il a frôlé la mort et qu'il
peut encore mourir et pourquoi
attendons-nous bien trop souvent les
tragédies pour dire à nos proches que
nous les aimons
pourquoi bien trop souvent attendre ces
moments là pour dire aux personnes que
nous apprécions plus ce que nous aimons
shevell pourquoi attendre les
enterrements pour faire l'éloge de nos
proches et même vous au quotidien
pourquoi attendre bien trop souvent les
départs les pots de départ pour
reconnaître les personnes que vous
côtoyez au quotidien pour célébrer ce
qu'il ya de meilleur en elle pour
célébrer leurs forces
alors oui peut-être que vous avez
l'impression de le faire déjà peut-être
le fait vous déjà mais ce n'est pas
assez
aujourd'hui sept personnes sur dix ne
s'estime pas apprécié à sa juste valeur
au travail alors même que nous savons
que la reconnaissance est un besoin
psychologique fondamentale la
reconnaissance l'estiment
pourquoi pourquoi nous ne le faisons pas
et ce par pudeur par peur du jugement
par peur de l'interprétation ont
peut-être peur de paraître naïf
vulnérables je sais pas mais ce dont je
suis sûr c'est qu'il faut le faire parce
que ça vaut le coup parce que il y a des
émotions qui valent la peine d'être
partagée il y a des mots qui valent la
peine d'être écrit dans le marbre et en
temps de vie alors comment faire comment
faire pour passer à l'action maintenant
comment faire pour agir concrètement
moi j'aimerais le faire mais ça ça fait
pas partie de mes automatismes
alors j'aimerais qu'on m'aide j'aimerais
qu'on m'y entraîne ici dans cette quête
d'outils intelligents pour passer à
l'action nous composions avec le monde
d'aujourd'hui
et si nous utilisions le meilleur du
monde moderne pour dire au monde ce que
nous en tant qu'être humain avant de
meilleures la technologie et l'humain et
si nous réconcilions comme à beyrouth
ces deux mondes
eh bien c'est ce que nous sommes en
train de faire pour la première fois
avec leeson léon ce mouvement de
générateurs de bienveillance à
l'intérieur de la société civile de vos
organisations et des écoles et ça c'est
en train de se passer maintenant
oui ce sont eux ces générateurs de
bienveillance qui concrètement au
quotidien font oeuvre d'humanité en
transmettant des compliments à leur
entourage
oui une application des compléments
gratuit désintéressé anonyme pour
libérer de façon différée dans le temps
un vrai cadeau surprise parce que
l'anonymat ici c'est la garantie d'un
compliment sincère authentique
désintéressé pur vrai et puis grâce au
meilleur de la tête donc grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle grâce à
l'analyse sémantique de ces témoignages
forts profond nous allons pouvoir
révéler à chaque utilisateur la
cartographie de ces forces
oui parce que ne serait ce pas plus
pertinent de mettre en lumière nos
forces plutôt que de vouloir pointer du
doigt nos défauts nos faiblesses prendre
conscience de ses forces pour les
développer en les partageant aux autres
notre ambition c'est d'introduire le don
comme lien social dans l'entreprise et
la société civile
[Musique]
alors j'entends peut-être certains
d'entre vous dans la salle peut-être
vous se dire mais au fond pourquoi avoir
besoin d'une application pour faire ça
et même ne serait ce pas dangereux nous
pourrions opposé technologie humains
ancien et nouveau monde
prenez par exemple cette dystopie
décrite dans la série black mirror où
les individus sont en apparence bon
cordiaux les uns avec les autres
mais ça c'est uniquement pour accéder à
un statut social avoir de bonnes notes
et là vous avez raison d'avoir peur car
certaines plates formes ne sont pas loin
de cela on s'envoie des mercis public
des bravos entre collègues et c'est à
celui qui en reçoit en donnent le plus
mais les dystopie ça marche
en chine un système de crédit social de
notation entre citoyens est en mach
divulguer les personnes ou entreprises
indigne de confiance
telle est la promesse de la plateforme
pilotée par pékin
et d'ici la fin 2020 le gouvernement
chinois aura déjà analysé les données
récoltées pour récompenser ou punir
quelques 22 millions de citoyens donc la
big brother c'est nous tous ici au
contraire nous proposions un modèle de
société purement altruiste
ça tient qu'à nous on peut le faire
maintenant concrètement alors peut-être
encore certains pourraient se dire mais
au fond est-ce que ce serait pas ça le
monde des bisounours
parce qu'on l'entend souvent qu'au fond
s'envoyer des compliments désintéressé
pure ne serait ce pas la pure utopie
justement eh bien non le réalisme et le
pragmatisme sont tombées cet argument
jacques leconte docteur en psychologie
avec une rigueur incroyable dans son
livre la bonté humaine démontre par des
faits anciens et récents par des preuves
scientifiques qu'il existe en nous une
potentialité y met à la bonté à
l'altruisme et à l'empathie et donc
c'est cette potentialité là qu'il faut
activer maintenant arriver ce que
j'aimerais c'est d'arriver à transcender
ce biais négativité que nous arrivions à
voir dans chacun d'entre nous au premier
abord ce qu'il ya de plus beau
plutôt que de pointer du doigt au
premier abord nos différences nos
défauts pour aller plus loin en 2015
les chercheurs fox kaplan et damasio ont
mené une étude corrélat neuronaux de
gratitude les résultats de l'étude
démontrent que lorsque les participants
éprouve de la gratitude cela active la
partie préfrontal de leur cortex cela
active le cortex cingulaire antérieur et
le cortex médial préfrontal pour le dire
simplement ces zones du cerveau joue un
rôle dans la régulation de la pression
artérielle de rythme cardiaque de
l'anticipation de la prise de décision
de l'empathie et de l'émotion la
pratique de la gratitude active la
partie préfrontal de notre néocortex le
siège de l'intelligence et si la
gratitude nous rendait nous tous ici
plus intelligent aujourd'hui donc grâce
à la technologie
nous pouvons l'utiliser pour que la
reconnaissance approfondie intérieure ni
superficiel et public comme nous y
invite black mirror et les réseaux
sociaux actuels ni étatique et punitive
comme son nom l'indiqué l'expérience
chinoise et ne pas non plus se contenter
d'un simple merci degré zéro de la
reconnaissance et qui par défaut
caractérise notre société mais vraiment
prendre le temps de poser un acte
altruiste fort
prendre le temps de célébrer l'autre
pour écrire un mot pourquoi attendre les
tragédies pour faire oeuvre d'humanité
d'altruisme
cette question se pose encore et
malheureusement pour longtemps
probablement mais ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que ensemble ici et maintenant
nous pouvons passer à l'action
[Musique]
alors ce que j'aimerais vous demander de
faire ce soir c'est de faire appel à
votre mémoire
observez vos proches votre entourage
sous leur meilleur jour vos familles vos
pères vos collègues peu importe
observez les sous leur meilleur jour et
prenez le temps prenez le temps de leur
écrire un mot en toute discrétion comme
l'avait prédit le grand
neuroscientifique français henri la
baule l'avenir de l'espèce humaine tient
dans la découverte de nouveaux rapports
humains entre les individus
alors soyez de ceux qui dès ce soir
feront qu'une connexion nouvelle révèle
non le pire mais le meilleur d'eux mêmes
merci
[Applaudissements]